la guerre des abonnements de cinéma
reprend prière le conseil de la
concurrence a autorisé ugc à vendre sa
carte annuelle qui donne droit à des
séances illimitée réaction immédiate de
la ministre la culture en désaccord
catherine tasca a engagé une procédure
de sanction charlotte millet doc luc et
rebelote
ugc reviennent à la charge avec sa
fameuse carte qui permet pour 98 francs
par mois d'assister à un nombre illimité
de séance le distributeur avait suspendu
sa vente le 9 mai dernier suite à une
plainte déposée par les autres réseaux
or le conseil de la concurrence n'a pour
l'instant fait état d'aucune pratiques
déloyales
savez vous prenez une classe de convoyer
de 40 france
prenez deux fois vous amortissez déjà le
prix pour
- comme moi cinéphiles trois fois en
cinéphile d'accord mais jusqu'à quand
les petits exploitants tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
cette carte ugc en réalité n'est pas une
simple proposition commerciale c'est une
ouverture de guerre des prix qui en fait
pour seul but de prendre des parts de
marché aux autres concurrents et surtout
aux indépendants et là peut évidemment
de les faire disparaître car les petites
salles n'ont pas les moyens financiers
pour présenter la carte illimitée pour
les soutenir la ministre de la culture a
annoncé qu'elle prendrait des sanctions
financières contre le distributeur
en attendant elle prône la concertation
j'aimerais bien que j'essaie accepte de
se mettre autour d'une table de travail
avec les autres exploitants et
qu'ensemble ils trouvent que nous
trouvions des solutions commerciales des
solutions aussi conventionnel de
partenariat pour que les pratiques
commerciales qui peuvent être très
profitable pour les uns ne soit pas
nuisible à l'équilibré du marché
les petits se sentent menacés mais les
gros distributeurs préparent déjà leur
riposte l'un d'entre eux s'apprêterait à
sortir une carte identique